- Hi, I'm Maeghan from Khan Academy.
In this video,
we'll learn how to find
and assign exercises,
videos, and articles on Khan Academy
for your classes or students.
In order to create an assignment,
we recommend teachers start by finding
and assigning content right
from the assignments tab
on the teacher dashboard.
From the teacher dashboard,
select one of your classes,
and then click on assignments
on the left side navigation
to expand all of the
options under assignments,
and then click assign.
Now, select your preferred course
from the dropdown menu.
You will see the full content
for the course divided into units.
Units are organized into lessons,
which in turn contain videos,
articles, and exercises.
Courses that are already aligned
with the Common Core and AP
show the standards tag to each unit,
lesson, video, article, and exercise.
By clicking a piece of content,
you can view the
exercise, watch the video,
or read the article before
assigning it to students.
In addition, hovering
the cursor over a code
shows the text of that
Common Core standard.
When you find what you need,
check the boxes for individual pieces
of content or the entire lesson,
and then click assign.
While it may seem appealing
to assign an entire unit to a class,
we don't recommend this.
When you assign a unit to a class,
each item appears as a separate
assignment to students,
which means you could be giving students
20, 30, or even 60 assignments.
Whenever you assign a piece of content,
you need to choose the class or classes,
students, due date, and
time of the assignments.
You can assign to a specific class,
a few classes,
or all of your classes at once.
You can still assign for one student,
a group of students, or
all of your students.
There is also an option for teachers
to select the content they wish to assign,
but save the assignment for
some time in the future.
You can click assign
to send the assignment
to students immediately,
or click save and assign later
to save the assignments for a later time.
In addition, for exercises,
you can decide whether students
will receive the same
question in the same order,
or a set of questions selected at random
from that exercises item bank.
One note,
you can always view the complete item bank
for an exercise by
clicking the exercise name.
Teachers share that viewing the item bank
before creating an assignment
helps them ensure they
are the right questions
and help some flag any concerns
before assigning the content to students.
In the case of classroom practice,
the most common option is to ask students
to work on the same set of questions.
This allows you to quickly
identify common mistakes,
which highlights areas for reteaching
or allows you to quickly
identify common areas
of success to provide
opportunities for celebration.
If you are using assignments
for independent practice or homework,
many teachers prefer students
to work on different questions.
In these situations,
students are given a consistent number,
variety, and rigor of questions,
but because the questions
are not identical,
students are encouraged
to work independently.
Another way to make assignments
is through the skills report.
The skills report shows
the level of skill mastery
for every skill for every student,
which makes it a valuable
tool for assigning content
that meets the needs of each student.
Select the unit to expand the report
and view all of the
skills within the unit.
By hovering over the purple bar
to the right of the skill name,
you can get a quick view of the number
of students at each skill level.
By clicking on the skill name,
you can expand the view of the skill
to see which students in the class
are currently at each skill level.
You can then use the
assign this skill button
on the right hand side to assign the skill
to an individual student,
group of students, or all students.
The same popup that appears
in the assignment tab will appear here.
You can preview the types of questions
that are included in this exercise
by hovering over the
blue view exercise link.
Clicking on the link will take you
to the student view of the same exercise.
Many teachers suggest using
this report to assign skills
the students at the not started
or attempted levels to encourage them
to increase their practice
time on that skill.
Another way to make assignments
on Khan Academy is through the toolbar.
When you browse any
content on Khan Academy
from the student perspective,
as long as you are logged
into your teacher account,
the toolbar will appear
at the top of the page.
You can use the toolbar
to make assignments
using the same information you would
from the assignments tab or skills report.
One other thing.
You can also find the content you need
by using the search bar.
You can search by subject,
concept, or even by standards.
Common Core state standards
for K through 12 math
or AP standards for our AP courses.
You can then filter the results by videos,
articles, exercises, and more.
When you find the content you want,
click on the item and use the tool bar
to complete the assignment options.
If you ever need to edit
or delete an assignment,
use the manage tab under assignments.
Now that you have an idea of
how to create assignments,
a question we hear a lot is
what does this look like for students?
Students will find assignments
on their learner home page,
the page they see as soon as they log in,
under the assignments tab for each class.
Students will see all of
their active assignments,
past assignments,
and the due dates for
completing each assignment.
Assignments are organized by due date
with the soonest due date at the top.
As students complete their assignments
and work on each question,
they receive instant feedback
on how they are doing,
and both you and the student receive data
on their performance
almost instantaneously.
Students are enabled to
make several attempts
to complete the assignments,
and we encourage students to
learn from their own mistakes.
If you assign different
questions for each student,
they will receive a new
set of questions selected
at random on each attempt.
And just as a reminder,
students can also view
and complete assignments
for any class in the
Khan Academy mobile app.
We know this is a lot of
information to take in,
and we hope this helps you as teachers
to create assignments for
your students on Khan Academy.
Some concepts work particularly
well for classroom practice.
Choose concepts that are more difficult
or that can generate good
discussions and debates.
Start slowly by creating just
a few assignments to do in a class.
Most teachers recommend three
to five assignments per week.
Gradually, you will build up a
routine of using Khan Academy
that best meets the pace of your students.
We hope this video helps you
get started creating assignments
for your students on Khan Academy.